so this diagram right over here
describes a food web and a food web
models how energy and matter moves in an
ecosystem and we're going to use this
food web to answer some questions to
make sure we understand food webs
so the first thing i'm going to ask you
is what are the producers in this food
web
pause this video and see if you can
figure this out
all right now let's work through this
together the producers are the ones that
can take matter in the ecosystem in the
environment and energy from an outside
source usually the sun in order to
construct themselves and then also in
order to store that energy
and when you look at a food web
producers are going to have arrows
pointed away from them so they're
getting their energy and their matter
from the environment and then other
people are going to consume them and
we're going to talk about them in a
little bit but we can see here that the
kelp is a producer this is an aquatic
ecosystem that we're looking at but the
kelp is a producer there's no arrows
going into it so it's using the sun and
elements and atoms and molecules that
it's finding in its environment in order
to grow
and we can also see that's the case with
the phytoplankton it's also able to do
photosynthesis like the kelp and capture
that energy from the sun
now the next question i have is where
are the decomposers
pause the video and try to answer that
one
all right now you might remember
decomposers you can think about that's
where a lot of the energy and the matter
ends up to be decomposed and then
recycled again and be reused again by
the producers and if you're looking at a
food web it's these would be organisms
where all the arrows point to them but
you don't have any arrows coming from
them and over here it's clear that the
bacteria and there's many different
species of bacteria or many different
types of bacteria but the bacteria here
are the decomposers
next i am going to ask you about the
primary
primary
consumers
pause this video and see if you can
identify them
well primary consumers are consumers
that directly eat the producers
and so let's see who is eating the kelp
you have the sea urchin eating the kelp
you have the fish eating the kelp who's
eating the phytoplankton you have the
zooplankton eating the phytoplankton so
these are primary consumers
next let's think about secondary
consumers
secondary
these are those that eat
primary consumers pause the video and
think about that
well let's think about who's eating
these primary consumers you have
the otter
what's interesting is the fish is a
primary consumer because it consumes
kelp which is a producer but it also can
consume another primary consumer so a
fish or the fish here are both primary
and secondary consumers and then i think
we are done so you can see the general
notions here
the producers have arrows going away
from them but no arrows coming into them
because they're getting their energy
from the sun and they're using the
matter in the ecosystem
primary consumers are eating those
producers and you can see they have
arrows going into them and then they're
eaten by other folks
secondary consumers are those that eat
the primary consumers and then last but
not least you have the bacteria which
are decomposers where the arrows all
point to them and they continue to use
that energy and then they take those
nutrients those molecules and they put
them back into the ecosystem so that it
can be recycled again